[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire où on
parle des sujets qui font l'actualité
alors depuis le 20 janvier jusqu'au 29
mars inclus les futurs bacheliers font
leurs voeux pour l'enseignement
supérieur mais l'orientation se dessine
parfois bien en amont certains jeunes se
lancent dans la voie professionnelle des
leurs fins de scolarité au collège une
voie qui permet d'acquérir des
compétences professionnelles est-ce
aussi une voie vers l excellence on en
parle avec nos invités david gratot
bonsoir
vous êtes le doyen doyen inspecteurs de
l'aide de l'éducation nationale second
degré à l'académie de versailles varie
vers les reee le galicia bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes vice doyenne inspecteur de
l'éducation nationale second degré vous
aussi à l'académie de versailles et
isabella la région bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes proviseur du lycée polyvalent violé
le dic à villiers saint frédéric david
gratos je vais commencer avec vous déjà
est-ce qu'on peut préciser ce qu'est la
voie professionnelle en fait ce sont
deux niveaux de nombreux niveaux d'étude
dans de très nombreuses filières oui
tout à fait donc effectivement les
formations professionnelles s'ouvre à
l'issue d'un parcours de troisième après
donc une offre à peu près de 105 entre
bach et puis de son ca paix et en
parallèle donc et il existe aussi des
mentions complémentaires des projets
professionnels des bts au sein du cursus
et puis des licences professionnelles
répandu sur différents secteurs
d'activités en lien avec du commerce et
du domaine industriel du bâtiment et
plein d'autres secteurs alors l'académie
de versailles est pourvu d'un cfa
académique il a été créé en 2009 avec
cinq apprentis à l'époque il accompagne
aujourd'hui 2100 apprentis sur l'année
2021 2022 avec près de 70 établissements
concernés sur toute l'académie c'est
plus de 178 parcours qui sont proposés
on vous le présente rapidement
c'est un service du rectorat qui permet
le développement de la modalité de
formation en apprentissage et qui
accompagne aussi les établissements
notamment les lycées de l'académie donc
sur les quatre départements
nous accompagnons sentiments les
établissements qu'ils le souhaitent
qu'ils souhaitent ouvrir des formations
en apprentissage mais évidemment nous
accompagnons aussi les candidats à
l'apprentissage
globalement en proposant des formations
qui vont du ca paix jusqu'à la licence
voire au delà parce qu'on a aussi des
partenariats avec des universités
douze secteurs d'activités qui vont de
l'industrie en passant par les services
à la personne le tertiaire aussi le
commerce le bâtiment la gastronomie avec
le pôle hôtellerie restauration donc
assez variés
[Musique]
on propose différents types
d'accompagnement on a en direction des
établissements effectivement un
accompagnement administratif et
pédagogique par le biais des corps
d'inspection ça c'est quand même très
important et puis nous avons aussi un
accompagnement en direction des
apprentis un accompagnement pour trouver
un employeur un accompagnement social
pour ceux qui ont des difficultés
puisque on a aussi des apprentis qui
peuvent rencontrer des difficultés et un
accompagnement des apprentis en
situation de handicap avec la cellule
insertion du rectorat donc nous
travaillons de pair pour pouvoir les
accompagner adapter l'enseignement
adapter les infrastructures aussi quand
c'est possible
[Musique]
valérie de galice et 12 secteurs c'est
ce qui est dit dans le sujet ça paraît
énorme on se rend pas compte finalement
que la voie professionnelle ouvre autant
de portes autant de perspectives
oui tout à fait c'est ça la richesse ont
également de cette voie professionnelle
elle elle permet à des élèves de réels
de ceux réalisés dans des voix
extrêmement diverse et je pense que
c'est pour c'est pour ça qu'il est très
important dès le collège d'avoir une
information très clair sur l'orientation
dans cette voie puisque finalement les
élèves de collèges ont des difficultés à
se représenter
c'est tout tout le champ des possibles
vers la voie professionnelle à 14 ans et
parfois on peut dire de se projeter sur
ce qu'on fera à 20 20 voire plus âgés
ils avaient là l'argent vous êtes la
chef d'établissement du lycée polyvalent
viollet le duc vous avez des filières
générales technologiques et donc
professionnelle et votre lycée est
labellisé lycée des métiers de l'habitat
et du développement durable oui en effet
et la proportion des yens en
apprentissage est en augmentation
constante parce que sur des filières en
baccalauréat professionnel et au delà
sur des sections de techniciens
supérieurs on a à présent une
soixantaine d'apprentis
des apprentis qui sont plus du côté de
l'artisanat on se rend pas
nécessairement compte habitat
développement durable ça les amène vers
quel type de métier allez on on parle
des baccalauréats professionnels
il y a essentiellement deux filières
dans lesquelles ils sont représentés à
savoir la filière aménagements finition
du bâtiment ils vont travailler sur tout
ce qui est revêtements intérieurs
cloisons
carrelage peinture
tout ce qui a trait à a
finalement à la mise en valeur du 1
logement à l'état brut ou dans le lieu
en aménagement et puis dans la partie
l'installation
de chauffage climatisation et énergies
renouvelables là on a aussi des
apprentis qui se dirige vers des métiers
autour des domaines vaste de la
plomberie quand on parle d'installation
climatique on est là dedans et aussi des
milliers des métiers de l'électricité de
l'électronique connectés donc autour de
la domotique finalement on est sur des
référentiels de métiers qui sont en
évolution constante et qui les amène à
mettre en oeuvre à utiliser des
techniques
aujourd'hui
énergétique
dans le cadre de développement durable
pour consommer m'en faire attention à
l'efficacité énergétique de leur
production des problématiques
d'aujourd'hui et de demain voilà
exactement et puis un bts et poursuivre
alors la question de société c'est de
voir si la voie professionnelle est
aussi celle de l'excellence alors les
filières ces dernières années et pour
certaines particulièrement sont mises en
avant dans des émissions de télé
principalement la restauration mais
david gratot est-ce que ça aussi permis
de voir un nouveau regard sur ces
formations professionnelles
alors oui effectivement les filières
d'excellence en fait c'est ce qui permet
à des élèves de se projeter vers des
secteurs d'activité où il ya de
l'insertion professionnelle où il ya
vraiment une vraie sensibilité par
rapport à une attente des territoires et
vous avez parlé de télé restauration et
qui effectivement une filière
d'excellence 1 qui permet
c'est un moment à certains jeunes de se
profiler vers des concours de meilleur
apprenti de france meilleur ouvrier de
france et on voit bien on imagine bien
les capacités qui ont permis à des
jeunes de d'aller vers l'excellence et
puis d'autres secteurs d'activités sur
notamment des secteurs industriels si on
peut parler de la filière aéronautique
par exemple on a plein de filières
permettent à des jeunes de se projeter
vers des situations concrètes et de
s'engager vers des poursuites d'études
très intéressante par la suite tout au
long de leur carrière professionnelle
isabelle à la régence cette question de
l'excellence ces notions que les
partager avec viollet le duc est ce que
finalement différence et la
professionnalisation de la voie générale
qu'on connaît le plus
alors c'est pas contents qu'on leur
différent si c'est comme essayer de
rendre complémentaires et puis la
première des tâches des professeurs de
l'enseignement professionnel c'est
souvent de réconcilier des élèves qui
ont été en difficulté précédemment avec
une forme d'ambition scolaire est donc
tombé sion professionnels c'est en ce
sens que ce n'est pas opposable qui plus
est on retrouve on a parlé l'instant de
concours comme le meilleur apprenti de
france lorsqu'on présente des élèves
dans à ce type de concours c'est
extrêmement valorisant ou seulement pour
l'élève mais pour toute la filière et
c'est quelque chose qui finalement
rejoint 10 à l'échelle d'un
établissement donc qui impacte aussi
positivement les élèves de
l'enseignement général parce que
finalement ils se sont côtoyés tout
jusqu'à la fin de 3e c est la muse
connaissent jusqu'à un moment ils
suivent des parcours différents alors
pour certaines générations la voie
professionnelle pouvait à une époque
être une un synonyme d'échec dans ses
études on pouvait entendre le fameux
passe ton bac d'abord ça a été
popularisé par un film de maurice piret
qui est sorti en 78 valérie le galicia
c'est une rengaine qui a plutôt tendance
à disparaître ou la voie professionnelle
a encore parfois cette image d'études
par défaut
alors il serait faux de dire que
justement cette image dégradée n'existe
plus malheureusement mais
je crois que la voie professionnelle à
de nombreux ressorts de nombreux levier
pour montrer aux collégiens que ce n'est
pas une voie de relégation on a parlé d'
excellence tout à l'heure et je crois
que les transformations la
transformation depuis la rentrée 2010 8
qui est en oeuvre montre que justement
on en est pas qu en échec dans la voie
professionnelle
alors on n'a pas cité tout à l'heure
mais je crois que c'était un bon exemple
de réalisation de l'excellence des
savoir-faire de nos élèves c'est les
chefs-d'oeuvre qu'il réalise aujourd'hui
en deux ans pour laisser happer première
année deuxième année de ces ap et puis
en bac pro 1re et terminale bac pro on a
là des élèves qui sont engagés sur des
projets et qui autour d'un projet qui
définissent avec leurs enseignants et
bien apprennent à des gestes
professionnels mais aussi des projets
qui ont qui ont un sens qui s'inscrivent
parfois dans de grands dynamique comme
éducation au développement durable ou
bien les valeurs de la république on a
en fait des chefs-d'oeuvre sont des
chefs-d'oeuvre
justement de la république donc voilà
c'est aussi ça la voie professionnelle
et ce qui permet de sortir un petit peu
de cette spirale de l'échec on a des
élèves d'ailleurs qui poursuivent leurs
études en bts ou dans d'autres
formations supérieures donc la voie
professionnelle n'est pas une voie de
relégation et l'accompagnement des
élèves est là aussi pour parfois les
sortir de cet échec scolaire dans
lesquelles il était auparavant alors en
décembre dernier tous les deux madame le
galibier et monsieur gratot aviez
réalisé une web radio autour d'une
question pourquoi la voie
professionnelle justement ce gratte au
pourquoi on se lance dans cette voie
quand on a 14 15 un peu plus âgés
parfois
alors ce qui est intéressant dans cette
voie c'est par rapport au collège on est
quand même centré sur l'acquisition de
savoirs
là on a la possibilité de s'étendre à
d'autres
compétences et notamment la découverte
des savoir faire des gestes
professionnels la connaissance de la
matière des matériaux des équipements de
plateaux techniques laboratoire et essai
avant tout l'apprentissage par le
concret c'est à dire que au moment
justement de l' approche pédagogique on
lit avec les enseignants indirectement
les élèves sont
tout de suite
en cohérence avec
les différentes disciplines et
différentes matières au sein de la
transformation de la voie
professionnelle il ya eu la mise en
place de deux co un terme ancion on a
des enseignants plutôt du domaine
général est en lien avec les enseignants
du domaine professionnel qui co animent
des cours ce qui permet d'être vraiment
en permanence dans le concret ce qui
n'est pas forcément le cas au niveau 2
du collège où d'autres voies que vous
avez cités tout à l'heure c'est ça ce
qui est vraiment intéressant pour les
mettre dans des situations de réussite
ça et pour et bien les accompagner
ensuite vers des projets qui le
souhaiteraient faire
isabelle et la région on l'a vite fait
dit tout à l'heure parce que le monde de
l'habitat et du développement durable ce
sont des métiers d'avenir des métiers de
demain dans votre établissement vous
préparer notamment les élèves un bac
professionnel aménagement et finition du
bâtiment et dans le contenu de la
formation quand on creuse un peu il ya
de l'économie de la gestion français
histoire-géo mathématiques et prévention
santé environnement je fais pas tout
citer mais on le voit c'est déjà très
complet et les matières que vous citez
qu'en partie du tronc commun de toutes
les filiales dans les métiers de
l'habitat et au delà de ça vous avez
véritable filière que l'on peut
qualifier de scientifiques puisque nous
avons
toutes les filières autour de technicien
géomètre topographe et techniciens
d'études du bâtiment avec des
spécialisations d'assistant d'architecte
ou alors d'études et d'économie du
bâtiment ce sont des élèves qui ont plus
dans un partenariat dans le cadre de
dispositifs d'égalité des chances
avec l'école supérieure d'architecturé
de versailles et qui peuvent prétendre
ensuite pour les meilleurs d'entre eux à
poursuivre dans cette école là donc ils
sont là directement
confronté on va dire à des exigences
d'écoles supérieures de très grande
qualité qui accueille aussi des élèves
qui viennent de voix général de voies
technologiques et eux ils ont déjà d'en
savoir faire technique qu'ils vont
ensuite
mettre à profit dans ces formations ils
auront évidemment à se mettre à niveau
sur d'autres disciplines en plus dans
l'actualité il ya peu à versailles c'est
le campus versailles patrimoine et
artisanat d'excellence qui a été
inaugurée il s'agit d'un pilote les
premiers élèves ont débuté en octobre
c'est une nouvelle démonstration dans
l'académie de versailles dans
département des yvelines des métiers que
l'on peut faire et que l'on peut
apprendre monsieur gratot madame le
galice et je ne sais pas qui est qui
veut répondre
effectivement à deux voix donc on a
effectivement des campus éviter les
qualifications avec une catégorie
excellence pour certains qui prennent
place dans un paysage de l'offre de
formation globale c'est qu'en plus
l'intérêt en la possibilité j'irai de
travailler avec différents opérateurs de
formation qu'ils soient privés ou
publics
d'avoir des parcours de formation venue
l'ère permettant est bien de mobiliser
le meilleur d'eux les professionnels qui
serait à même de transmettre des élèves
et puis c'est l'occasion aussi justement
de valoriser des formations d'excellence
qui malheureusement sont peu ou moins
connus dans le paysage et il devient
essentiel voire urgent de de se
préoccuper justement de certains c'est
un certain métier qui ont plutôt
tendance à disparaître et qui sont
vraiment essentiel pour agir et
sauvegarder notre patrimoine peut-être
pas des flics mais peut-être ajouter que
c'est aussi
une belle synergie avec l'enseignement
supérieur on a par exemple au campus
d'excellence de versailles 1 des u donc
qui s'adresse à des élèves qui ont leur
pack et un début tout à fait original
puisqu'il s'intitule de la terre à la
table il fait découvrir il ya un autre
début de ce type là il fait découvrir en
fait aux élèves qui sont inscrits sur
une année post bac
l'ensemble des métiers et des
compétences
liées justement aux questions de
l'agriculture aux questions de
l'alimentation aux questions de la
restauration puisqu'on et de la terre à
la table voilà une dynamique tout à fait
originale innovante de formation donc
les campus ont aussi cette vocation la 1
mettre en synergie les acteurs du lycée
à la à l'université avec des partenaires
du monde économique très intéressant on
a beaucoup parlé de ces jeunes qui a au
troisième selon après la 3e pardon se
lance dans la voie professionnelle mais
ça peut se tenter à tout âge quand on
prépare l émission madame alain les gens
vous me disiez que n'y a pas que des
jeunes c'est ce que me permettre les
guillemets via les adultes aussi qu'ils
se lancent dans ces formations oui tout
à fait on est dans une période où il ya
aussi pas mal de reconversion
professionnelle et nous nous sommes
aussi support du greta des yvelines
c'est l'organisme de formation de
l'éducation nationale qui s'appuie en
fait sur les lycées et les collèges
en termes de rh mais aussi en tant que
deux plateaux techniques donc en
dispense des adultes soit qu'ils sont en
voie de professionnalisation signe parce
que il à certains qui sont à la
recherche d'une première qualification
soit parce qu'ils ont envie de donner
une nouvelle orientation à leur parcours
professionnel eh bien nous dispensons
des formations qui vont là aussi
jusqu'au titre professionnel de niveau
bac + 3 on parlait de l'image tout à
l'heure justement monsieur gratton
madame excusez moi je trouve sur votre
nom est légalisée est-ce que auscitains
les adultes comme vous les voyez revenir
sur ces voies de professionnalisation
ces changements peut-être qu'on fait des
hauts diplômes si je peux me permettre
le mot on a cette évolution c'est dans
la société de revenir à des métiers
qu'on disait peut-être parfois disparu
aussi
with qu'intéressant et d'ailleurs c'est
les parcours que l'on voit de plus en
plus
on accompagne de plus en plus d'adultes
en reconversion madame l'art il a évoqué
juste à l'instant on peut être un
phénomène de société pour redonner
peut-être du sens aux tirs et un certain
apprentissage et puis à certains métiers
encore une fois
il est parfois intéressant de
dans notre société de veut réaliser de
3,4 carrière totalement différente pour
et bien faire peut-être ce que l'on
selon m vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure passe ton bac d'abord mais
peut-être que certains aujourd'hui après
la période que l'on traverse se disent
mais finalement est-ce qu'il n'est pas
le plus intéressant de faire ce que ce
que l'on aime et de créer de réaliser
des choses concrètes
peut-être madame de belcier
oui c'est je crois un message important
à faire passer aux élèves c'est à dire
que la formation c'est vraiment tout au
long de la vie
la formation ne s'arrête pas aussi ap ne
s'arrête pas au bac on peut même pas
mince et a fait un bac pro accéder à
d'autres fonctions et de toute façon les
métiers de demain ne les connais pas
encore donc il vaut mieux se préparer à
cette perspective de me changer de
métier peut-être une fois deux fois
trois fois dans sa vie parce que parce
que tel est le monde aujourd'hui voilà
un monde mouvant voir s'adapter et on
prépare aussi nos élèves à cette
perspective là dans la voie
professionnelle
il s'appelle à la région vous vous
faites y réagir oui parce que on le voit
non très clairement comme une évolution
sociétale il y a des moments clés il y a
quelques années de ça il y avait
beaucoup de reconversion autour de la
pâtisserie de la restauration
aujourd'hui on voit beaucoup de choses
entraîné avec l'économie durable avec le
recyclage avec la recherche utilisation
de matériaux
qui sont des matériaux anciens mais qui
aujourd'hui font état d'une d'une grande
technicité et par exemple chez nous pour
les métiers du bois qu'il s'agisse des
métiers autour de la construction mois
donc charpente menuiserie ou alors
autour de vraiment là l'agencement la
menuiserie d'intérieur il y à des
adultes qui sont extrêmement demandeurs
mais justement pour ceux qui
s'interrogeraient sur ces filières de la
voie professionnelle il ya un forum
organisé à guyancourt ce vendredi 4
décembre il y a dix secteurs d'activités
qui sont représentés comme le btp
l'agriculture ou encore la métallurgie
il y en a un autre c'est celui du campus
versailles dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure il se déroule du 10 au 12
février
je remercie mes trois invités de s'être
rendus disponibles pour participer à
cette émission vous l'avez compris le
statut de société maintenant terminé
merci à nos téléspectateurs nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau mouvement des
changes et bien sûr d'ici là prenez bien
soin de vous
[Musique]